all right comprehensive dental care the
sponsors of this next segment are ready
to give you a new bright and functional
smile here's how
it's estimated that over 175 million
americans have at least one missing
tooth so comprehensive dental care is
here to educate that population on their
best options my practice is focused
mainly on dental implants and
single tooth
restorations and full arch
replacement of teeth
i've been doing dental implants for 25
years
i am a diplomat of the american board of
oral implantology a recognized
dental implant specialist in other words
dr hendrickson knows what he's doing
he's also one of the national full arts
restoration trainers for highbridge
dental lab which helps his practice stay
focused on comfort aesthetics and
function if they come in and they're
wearing a denture
like this
we know
statistically that they've lost about 90
percent of their
function they've lost taste because this
covers the roof of their mouth
often times their anatomy limits the
stability of this in their patient's
mouth so they have to perhaps live with
denture adhesive all the time with the
high bridge the full arch restoration is
fixated and screwed into the patient's
mouth it's going to fit feel and
function
the most natural
it's going to give them their ability
back to eat
and enjoy foods another reason why
patients prefer the functional hybrid
system is because it supports optimal
bone health over time
the bone in the jaw melts away
if we take the teeth out we know for a
fact that every year the patient comes
back with the denture in place
they're going to lose gum tissue and
bone
the full arch implants stimulate the
bone and restores its health and
functionality making the implant last a
lifetime you know if you come to me and
say craig you know what the teeth are
kind of worn down
it's been 10 years since you put these
in
i can go ahead and remove these from the
patient's mouth send them back to the
laboratory
and they literally do a retread on these
for less than the cost of a crown you
have a new set of teeth and maintenance
with regular dentures you're looking at
five to seven hundred dollars per reline
now according to dr hendrickson the
process of putting the hybrid in is
relatively pain free patients typically
say the first 18 hours are the worst
with some soreness the next day the
surgery is typically done in the morning
and we bring it back in the next day and
we do a digital scan
and three weeks later we can screw the
your teeth into your mouth and they're
not done
you know if you look at somebody's face
and eyes
that have dental problems
it may sound cliche but sometimes they
kind of come in kind of lifeless because
they
they're not they don't like their smile
they're not happy with it so they're not
smiling
and when we can give them that smile
back their whole face lights up
you can visit comprehensive dental care
for a free consultation with dr
hendrickson himself to discuss your
needs and your new smile
for sponsoring this segment if you'd
like more information you can call 70273
or visit
indiedentist.com las vegas now